Big publishing company.
They lost a bunch of money one year,
and their executive team for three days visualized their entire practice.
And what's interesting is that after visualizing the entire business,
systems upon systems,
they reclaimed 50 million dollars of revenue,
and they also moved from a D rating to an A rating from their customers.
Why? Because there's alignment from the executive team.
So I'm now on a mission to help organizations
solve their wicked problems by using collaborative visualization,
and on a site that I've produced called drawtoast.com,
I've collected a bunch of best practices.
and so you can learn how to run a workshop here,
you can learn more about the visual language
and the structure of links and nodes that you can apply to general problem-solving,
and download examples of various templates
for unpacking the thorny problems that we all face in our organizations.
So the seemingly trivial design exercise of drawing toast
helps us get clear, engaged and aligned.
So next time you're confronted with an interesting challenge,
remember what design has to teach us.
Make your ideas visible, tangible, and consequential.
It's simple, it's fun, it's powerful,
and I believe it's an idea worth celebrating.
Thank you.
(Applause)